there are a lot of films that probably
come to mind when you think about
superheroes the genre covers an insane
range of movies but a special few
definitely stand out above the rest from
the Marvel and DC universes to a few
outside the box superhero films these
are the best superhero movies you
absolutely must see the Avengers the
Marvel Cinematic Universe currently
spends more than a dozen films and
Counting but the pinnacle of the
franchise was arguably established
relatively early on with the Avengers
the studio Kappa geek demigods Joss
Whedon to write and direct a project and
the result was a critical and commercial
hit the Avengers remains one of the most
successful films ever made the movie
pulled in more than 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide and is still one of the
highest rated films in the MCU is a
comic book brought to life in the best
possible way thanks to Whedon's ability
to blend a bevy of characters and a
compelling story into one perfect
package The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
is widely considered one of the best
Batman interpretations ever put the
screen it's been more than a decade
since the trilogy launched so it's easy
to forget just how significant these
movies were for the franchise eight
years up to Batman and Robin bond
Nolan proved the Caped Crusader was
still viable on the big screen with
Batman Begins then raised the stakes
even higher with 2008 The Dark Knight
arguably the best of the bunch the film
is moody smart atmospheric and boasts
some of the best superhero action teams
ever put to film Heath Ledger's
performance as the Joker is a
particularly fine example of the genres
dramatic potential never start with the
head the victim gets all fuzzy he can't
feel the neck
see Captain America Civil War this
Captain America's sequel has been
described as Avengers 2.5 for good
reason
it featured as many heroes as your
typical Avengers film and told a
politically charged story that set
Earth's Mightiest Heroes against one
another in one of the most i popping big
screen battles ever conceived along with
giving fans high stakes
heroes vs. hero battles Civil War also
took a major step toward moving the MCU
forward it introduced chadwick boseman
black panthers to mainstream audiences
and gave us our first look for Tom
Hollands newest incarnation of
spider-man well I couldn't stick the
landing a little better it's just a new
suit way tape something mr. stark it's
perfect thank you yeah we don't really
need to start a conversation okay cap
captain The Incredibles we're calling it
right here now The Incredibles is one of
the best superhero movie ever
[Music]
Wow Brad bird's 2004 animated
masterpiece was basically a spin on the
classic Fantastic Four story but with so
much more it builds a fascinating world
and seamlessly grappled questions
adulthood and responsibilities in ways
kids and grownups could follow and
appreciate it's also crazy fun and laugh
out loud hilarious
[Music]
oh it's taken almost 15 years but a
sequel is finally in the works with the
release date set to 2019 because The
Incredibles need a sequel not but having
Brad Bird back in the saddle helps ease
our fears a little Iron Man this movie
is the granddaddy of the MCU and it's
just as good today as it was when a blew
our socks off in 2008 with heavy hitters
like an x-men and spider-man already
sold off to larger studios Marvel had to
pull heroes from the bench to launch a
shared universe Iron Man was one of the
best of the rest so they gave directed
Jon Favreau a lot of freedom and banked
on the charisma of Robert Downey jr. the
gamble worked and this movie managed to
tell an extremely fun story while
setting the time for the dozen or so
movies to follow there's also a textbook
example of how to get a superhero origin
story right on film
Deadpool it's an absolute miracle this
blood-soaked f-bomb drenched film ever
made it out of development hell but are
we all glad it did a Deadpool movie
kicked around in script form for years
but it took the leaked concept reel to
finally build enough momentum to get it
made the Merc with a mouth now holds the
record for the highest grossing x-men
film and the highest-grossing r-rated
film in history not bad for a b-list
comic character with a foul mouth what
does
Oh tanana x-men Days of Future past
combining the worlds of the original
x-men trilogy with the prequel sequel
x-men first class was a tall order but
Bryan Singer pulled it off in spades
with his return to the franchise Days of
Future past managed to deftly weed
together a story spanning decades with
two separate casts and still keep all
those narrative threads tight enough
that even casual fans could still follow
along
it also stealthily reckoned the
disappointing x-men The Last Stand
making all things right was in the
cinematic ex universe well not bad right
played - when the first played film
released in 1998 it turned out to be a
surprise box office hit the studio
brought in Guillermo del Toro to tackle
the sequel Blade 2 was basically
everything you loved about the first
film the better instead of just fighting
bloodsuckers daywalker blade is roped
into a larger fight for survival against
the positively terrifying reapers much
like x-men this film was an early
proving ground for serious adaptations
of superhero stories that predated the
Avengers and their pals by several years
Logan after the unanticipated mega
success of r-rated Deadpool 2017 slogan
finally allowed Jackman spirit animal
pistol copious amounts of blood sever
limbs and make full use of the colorful
vocabulary
he's long enjoyed in the comics [ __ ]
there's basically little miss sunshine
with superheroes Logan is a movie that
x-men fans never expected to actually
happen inspired by the classic Western
shame and very loosely based on Mike
Miller's old man Logan comics Logan
makes Wolverine interesting again as a
broken man with a failing healing factor
Sir Patrick Stewart gives one of the
best performances of his career but it's
Daphne Keens performance as the
merciless x-23 the elevator would be
grim character study into a must-see neo
westerns murdered pageant guardians of
the galaxy
this movie is just crazy fun Chris Pratt
star-lord proves
70s rock songs belong in out of space
and so do Marvel superheroes zoe saldana
enchants as the green-skinned assassins
with the conscience Gamora
Bradley Cooper shows his impressive
range is the voice of Rocket Raccoon and
Vin Diesel's Groot
makes three words speak volumes oh well
that's just it's fascinating in the
first 89 times you told me that job
Dallas's power seemed limited to
interdimensional conference calls and
brooding in his floating space jet and
Ronan the accusers actions defy common
understanding of the Infinity stars but
none of these discrepancies really
matter because it's just so much fun to
watch what are you doing I'm distracting
you big turd blossom thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel
Plus check out all these cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]